quatre invités ce soir julien c'est là
c'est la petite protégée de mylène
farmer qui fait son grand retour nous
par sur scène et on entend votre wii est
reconnaissant à tout ça je me suis
trompé c'est un sex-toy sexo c'est ce
que disaient aussi super et voilà à ce
stade je me suis tombé c'est le nouveau
single ça on a un goût du clip oui bon
on regarde
dégagez monte et la corée
[Musique]
pour lisicki
joli moment
me désengager et public
sancha
à
alors contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser ce n'est pas laurent boutonnat
qu'il a réalisé voilà mais on sent bien
la patte de femmes dans les photos d'art
comment est-ce qui vous ont approché par
téléphone je me doutais bien que des
formules un télégramme au moins je me
doutais ça doit faire bizarre quand même
parce que mes nerfs moeurs et je crois
que c'est là encore man de ventes
d'albums numéro 1 devant tout le monde
c'est une des plus grosses stars de la
chanson française voilà c'est un c'est
un phénomène
on doit tous sommes surpris parce que
j'imagine moi oui allô bonjour c'est
mylène farmer au téléphone je pense
qu'on est un peu en stand by et moi
voilà ah non mais vraiment j'ai cru que
c'était un canular téléphonique
et puis quand on a dit que c'était vrai
je me suis dit bon on verra bien
peut-être que je vais arriver que je
vais voir des gens ne sont pas dupes et
mylène farmer et laurent boutonnat
mais ils sont tout à fait normaux rod au
contraire oui sont tout à fait normaux
oui c'est ça il est comment arlette noc
et petits secrets pour partager avec
nous a alors évolué en vraie belle
équipe titre elle est très simple elle
et elle est très simple c'est une très
belle femme est très belle femme très
intelligente et très sensible en chine
qui est ce que ce soit vous vous serez
au concert au panier ce soir là moi
aussi dit don entre nous et nous alors
il est ce qu'on peut emmener tout le
monde mais mais mais mais non mais non
en tous les cas tu peux vous dire que là
c'est le retour de farmer il ya déjà
beaucoup de fans qui sont devant lui
la nuit d'adam des dix ans est depuis
mercredi mais oui on regarde moi eh bien
quand devant pour être au plus près de
la scène vous rendez compte tu me lis
tant qu'elle n'a pas fait ça fait six
ans un système mmi artisans déjà évident
et même si vous restez la sison nemec
fred houénou même précision devant le
but madonna française c'est la madonna
fait beaucoup ont acheté un ticket pour
chaque concert seront pas tous les
concerts alors yable on a on a on a on a
des images d'une fan de mylène farmer
les fans est allé un peu sosie aussi
alors à des sosies de loin 300 personnes
et la file continue de s'allonger
ioulia il me semble que vous avez fait
plus de 24 heures de bus vous venez
directement de varsovie pour voir me
lève tout à fait plus que vingt quatre
heures en bus pour l'instant je fais que
quatre dates mais après je pense à
acheter des billets supplémentaires
place assiste peut-être ça ça représente
combien pour le portefeuille
plus que cinq cents euros je crois tout
ça pour me l'inde mélèzes
quand on aime on ne compte pas et il me
semble d'ailleurs vous a appris le
français a pris le français grâce à
mylène farmer oui tout à fait j'ai
appris le français grasset mylène
j'avais 10 ans je crois mais l'un des
deux après des langues étrangères et à
être rouassi avoua là
[Applaudissements]